how does charles respond to this because
yeah the big loser in this thing yeah i
mean
there is a big loser in all of this and
the couple have made
a real point of speaking very warmly
about the queen
you know charles i was told by a source
very close to him was despairing
over this interview days before it went
out you wanted freedom from from that
life you wanted freedom to make your own
money
we didn't want to give up or we didn't
want to turn our backs on these the
associations and the people that we
that we've been supporting i had three
conversations with my grandmother
and two conversations with my father um
before he stopped taking my calls
and then said can you put this all in
writing what your plan is
when harry was emailing his father to
justify why he had done it
if charles was despairing before it one
can only imagine
how he's feeling after having watched it
and heard exactly what the couple have
to say
it's pretty bruising for charles there
is harry saying
that he felt let down by his father
revealing that
calls about really important things
went unanswered there came a point where
charles simply didn't want to hear
anymore
what harry and megan were proposing
instead he asked him
to put it in an email something harry
didn't want to do because he was
convinced it would leak
and harry was absolutely right it did
leak to the press and that's why he took
matters into his own hands
how does something like that an email
between father and son leak out
does charles say okay because clearly
i mean harry's writing an email to his
father you know how do emails like this
leak you know harry harry didn't want to
put anything on email because he was
always worried that it might be
intercepted it might be seen
by someone who didn't have his best
interests at heart i mean there was a
lot of
suspicion between harry and megan and
courtiers you know it had turned into a
very febrile atmosphere at the palace
one that was very toxic the couple felt
the palisades were out to get them
so you just said that your dad stopped
taking your calls why do you stop taking
your calls
by that point i took matters into my own
hands it was like i need to do this for
my family
this is not a surprise to anybody it's
really sad that it's got to this point
but i've got to do something for my own
mental health my wife's anthologies as
well because i could see where this was
headed
i think the situation with charles is
incredibly sad
because on the day of the royal wedding
it was charles who stepped in towards
him down the aisle it was one of the
proudest moments of his life and there
was no
faking that happiness there was no
faking that sense of inclusivity when he
put his arm around megan's mother doria
that was a picture of promise of hope
of optimism i think for the royal family
but i think it is
very damaging for charles's reputation
to be seen
as a cool and aloof father don't forget
he had that reputation around the time
of diana's death
people said he wasn't there enough for
his sons and that's why harry had gone
off the rails
well now here's harry saying himself
that
later on in life two his father wasn't
there for him and i think at a time when
charles's reputation is enjoying more
popularity than
arguably it ever has done he's been a
real hit
during the pandemic people have really
warmed to charles
this this is pretty damaging this is
this is damaging to his reputation
your family cut you off yeah in the
first half the first quarter of 2020
but i've got what my mum left me and
without that we would not have been able
to do this
what do you think your mom would say
about this stepping back this decision
to step back from the royal family how
would she feel about this moment i think
she would feel very angry
with how this is panned out and very sad
but ultimately all she'd have
all she'd ever want is for us to be
happy charles he is painted as the
villain basically in this interview
how do you think he comes out of this
well charles certainly doesn't come out
as a winner in
any of this and he i think will be
very concerned by what harry has said
harry has said that he felt let down by
his father
it must have been a very difficult thing
for harry to say publicly
but equally a very difficult thing for
prince charles
to hear he it does feel so terribly sad
is he taking your calls down yeah yeah
yeah
yeah there's a lot to work through there
you know i
i feel really let down
because he's been
through something similar he knows
what pain feels like and this is
and archie's his grandson um
but at the same time you know i of
course i will i will always
i will always love him but there's a lot
of hurt that's happened
this closeness quickly turned into
resentment and detachment when
essentially
charles wouldn't sit down and discuss
what harry and megan wanted
for their future on the phone and that's
when we understand the relationship
unraveled but for charles to hear
that he felt let down by harry will be
very very painful indeed
you